mitt romney voted against the nomination  of kintaji brown jackson to the dc  circuit court of appeals okay he thought  she wasn't qualified now this week mitt  romney announced that he is supporting  the same person's confirmation to the  supreme court  huh  so here's what it took for mitt romney  to finally support cantanji brown  jackson  he learned in the course of supreme  court confirmation hearings that she  gave lenient sentences to child  pornographers mitt romney apparently  didn't know that last year hence the  vote against her  now that he knows that kentucky brought  jackson has disregarded sentencing  guidelines to benefit kitty  pornographers  it's a yes for mitt romney  that's the junior senator from the state  of utah utah